Winston Wilson Wilson where you from
boom hit where you from oh hit boom
don't I get side I mean you yeah if you
want to play Black that's good you hit
bum B yeah I think he's in trouble he's
in trouble see wait a minute let me get
rid of this guy he's not
friendly whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa that was right there don't try to
trickery now is that how the trick works
that was like a magic trick I like the
way you did that nothing happen imagine
you what pie
disappear Bor that was some serious
Tripper let me take that from you wait a
minute wait a minute has happened to you
nothing comtable be comfortable be nice
what's going on now I've heard of this
rule called p p I heard of that oh yeah
oo that that's going to make it resign c
c c c c c c c c c I appreciate it
Grand I me c